friends we are in a battlefield of sorts
we are in the trenches taking grenades
in the dumpster as battlefield known as
the January moving business we're going
to get through that together I'm going
to help you do it by reviewing movie you
do not give a about including this
one now Sansa movies good or bad I'm
saying you give this right yeah you
don't
[Music]
leaplet so sleepless is a movie starring
Jamie Foxx Jamie Foxx and his partner of
these corrupt cops in Vegas they may
steal cocaine from this mob boss who's
not really happy about it so the hammer
starts coming down on Jamie Foxx like
give us our coke back because we
kidnapped your kid Jamie Foxx was like
you heard him I'll kill you but I'll get
your cocaine back in that I thought the
movie was gonna be a taken ripoff I saw
the trailers about a second not really
taking rip-off surprisingly through the
fact that he needs to get his kid back
that's kind of like taken but he does
not have this special set of skills that
Liam Neeson had nor is he trying to take
on the mob afraid he's trying to get
them their cocaine so we can get this
kid back well trying to hide the truth
dodge the cops it basically takes place
in one casino anyhow there are things
that work in this movie Jamie Foxx is
one of Jamie Foxx is a good actor Jamie
Foxx brings it in this movie this really
isn't absurd as movie's not a lot of
things make sense in here kind of like
pushing a Conair than it is taken I
don't mean from premises the premise is
not the same as Connor but you can tell
the movies still going for that 90s fun
action nonsense that makes very little
sense when you really look at it but
hopefully if you turn your brain off and
have fun they'd have a big Vegas chasing
at the end that could never happen scoot
mcnairy plays this really creepy ass
intense mobster guy is really a mobsters
son just makes him more of a dick it
would be really good villain in this
messy-ass movie does he always make good
decisions no but the movie never
addresses his bad decision making but
scoot mcnairy was read also Michelle
Monaghan Dre she plays a was going
after Jamie Foxx she's like I know
there's something fishy about this guy
that dude is crooked the to to place her
partner whose name I can't remember the
dude is genuinely good at everything I
see him and that said the movies either
not exciting at all or over the top in
that five ninety-two action way like I
said what never really hit fun 90s
action bracket a lot of the movies Jamie
Foxx talking with this person talking
with that person trying to find the
cocaine so he can get his kid back and
just make a clean trade for a couple of
sweet action scenes slash fights in the
movie I thought those were entertaining
and those are the glimpse that come
through this movie really like that was
well done the movie box down in the
pacing decision-making and general
knowledge that people actually have as
to how security works and how it would
work if someone who doesn't want to be
seen by the cops or arrested wants to
remain in the background like look I'm
here again has people know I'm involved
but I'm going to torture a guy in the
middle of a baseball stadium and if all
else
see on the end of the movie I'm going to
open fire in a nightclub in a casino
that dude would straight up go to prison
after that I know a lot of people in
this casino are corrupt people who are
not corrupt law enforcement would get
involved and they'd get the casino
security cameras when they find out that
dude was involved it would just be bad
for you but this movie fails on its just
knowing what it is and committing to
what it is some parts this movie wants
to be a legit movie some part that wants
to be an entertaining action movie in
the 21st century other times it wants to
harken back to the cheesy 90s action
movies sleepless doesn't really hit that
Goldilocks zone so the movie doesn't
really know what it wants to be there
are plenty of moments where you're like
those movie was competently made in
parts almost like this movie has three
directors one of those directors was
really good however as I'm not saying
hey go look sleepless it's so great I
will say I feel like this movie could be
salvaged depending on your blood alcohol
level and that I will say sleepless
would probably be a better time if
you're drunk
yeah and now is the party ok sleepless
have you seen it what did you think
about it or what your favorite 90s
action movie ish movie that was made
after the 90s whatever it is whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you liked what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]